Probably the last piece of advice for millennials
I’ll give is: resist any attempts to make
this about your choices rather than your options.
We get blamed for every single thing that
happens to us, that when we live far away
from work it’s “because we want to be
suburbanites,” and when we job hop to get
higher wages it’s “because we’re flighty,”
and when we live with our parents because
we have to, because the rent is too high,
it’s “because we’re lazy and we just
want to play video games all day.”
Next time anyone brings up anything about
your choices, tell them about how your options
have changed.
Our options are objectively much more difficult
now than they were for our parents.
Look up any statistic about wages, about the
prices of housing, healthcare and education,
about what kinds of jobs are available, and
it is objectively worse now.
It is not your fault.
It is the fault of the people who are not
interested enough to find out how things have
actually changed in this country.
I think it’s important to have a reality
check that most humans want a level of security
and most humans want prosperity for themselves
and their families.
And so when we say things like, “Millennials
don’t want to work,” or “millennials
want to move jobs every couple years,” what
we’re oftentimes expressing is that millennials
are working in an economy where they HAVE
to, where there’s all kinds of economic
data showing that if you want a raise the
best way to do that is to switch jobs.
So for a lot of us that are paying off our
student debts and paying way too much in rent—we
need to move jobs.
You don’t have to justify your life to get
a raise.
If your company is employing you they are
making money off of you, you are entitled
to some percentage of that money.
If bosses say they can’t afford you, then
threaten to leave—or leave!
I don’t see any reason – I think it’s
very important to keep in mind that your company
is fundamentally not loyal to you even if
the people are nice and even if your boss
is great; your company, the minute they need
to let you go, they will let you go.
And it’s time for you to have the same relationship
to them.
So frankly you do not have to tell your boss
about your student loans, you do not have
to tell your boss about your high rent, you
should go into your boss’s office every
year and tell him you should get paid more,
because you deserve it, and he is making money
off of you and you deserve a huge chunk of
that.
So I don’t think we should fall into the
trap of trying to use our poverty to get more
money out of our companies; I think we need
to hold them accountable to the fact that
they are making money off of our labor and
we are entitled to a percentage of it.
So I think we often times talk about economic
circumstances as if they are the preferences
of millennials when actually they are the
necessity of millennials.
So I think if you want to retain millennial
workers, treat them as people.
Consider that they are the same as people
in their 40s and 50s: they want a decent life,
they want a pension, they want pay, they want
to feel like they have meaning in their lives.
And give them that.
I mean we don’t - I don’t think there’s
any magic to having millennial employees.
I think: don’t hire them as contractors
and recognize their unions and pay them decently,
and then they won’t leave your company.
It’s not that hard.